Cordoba is famous for having the most
beautiful interior courtyards in Spain
where they are called patios
each year the Andalusia City gears up
for its annual patio festival local
resident Rafael Cordoba is among those
taking part he's putting the finishing
touches on the flowerpots and sprucing
up the plots on his patio good play
muchas muchas flora look what I see I
have 400 flower packs so that's a lot of
wilted leaf to remove the ellicott when
you're not busy watering you're applying
fertilizer or paint this house is very
old from the 16th century
Araceli Lopez is also doing some
last-minute tidying up before the
visitors start streaming in she shows us
her trusted and traditional watering
system a long stick and a tin can at a
sellable this property just a little
while ago a city mall we decided to buy
the house so that we could preserve this
old patio it's at least 350 years old
siento cincuenta aproximadamente
courtyard in Cordoba
date back to Roman times designed to
provide houses with a cool refuge from
the heat the tradition was continued by
the Moors who built the Great Mosque and
now Cathedral left a lasting impact on
local architecture despite the city
returning to Christian rule in 1236 jail
even most kill el calor you know the
colors and scents came with the Arabs
they love these vertical gardens but
wanted to keep them to themselves pero
para they closed the doors and enjoyed
their patios Edie from Daraa
most of the city's four thousand
courtyards are still closed today but
around 60 open up to visitors during the
14 day festival it means long queues
outside homes like Raphael cordobas but
the wait is well worth it we already
thought very beautiful we're here for
the first time and we like it though
we've only seen three or four I didn't
expect it to be this nice the malapa
Darcy soon aqua tell you what it's
rather unique you really have to be in
the patios to understand the colors the
sense and the light wonderful it's the
slogan tomorrow yeah
not just locals and tourists visit the
courtyards the festival is also a
contest and so a judging panel stops by
to cast their votes for the best patios
there are different categories for
historical patios and more contemporary
ones every year close to 50 courtyards
take part in the competition this time
one of the judges is a biologist for her
it's about more than just the lovely
colors
mmm-hmm nobody are flawed and of course
the variety of flowers plays a role but
it's the atmosphere that really matters
the water the music and what we can
smell as we come in everybody quando
chega it's all about that initial
emotion and we'll meet the first
courtyards festival was celebrated in
1918 it dates back to a time when large
single-family villas were turned into
multi-family homes the rooms were so
small that people spent a lot of time in
the courtyard cada uno de nova su parte
calibishie know la parte residents would
decorate their entrances in table
painting the flower pots as they liked
and because it was particularly
delightful in the spring they decided to
open their doors to visitors so they
could see all the beauty on display para
que todo visit on take a Vienna gear
polka entrada al gay esta vez
[Music]
the crowds have been coming ever since
locals like Raphael make a huge effort
to make their prized patios even more
beautiful to win over the judges he's
won countless awards but his real
motivation is the memories the chickadee
you ever knew luckily there were flowers
here when I was a child my grandparents
have since died so I want to keep their
memory alive in the patio and the
flowers well every year people come from
far and wide to witness a unique
spectacle as the courtyard of Cordoba
spring into bloom
[Music]